le dossier de l'aménagement du bas
belleville à nouveau sur le devant de la
scène les associations refusent le
lancement de la zac ramponneau
belleville mais l'hôtel de ville veut
faire aboutir ce vieux projet un dossier
très sensible une pierre d'achoppement
entre la majorité les maires socialistes
du 20e arrondissement
béatrice pignède et josiane rimouski
branle bas de combat à la bellevilloise
après une victoire durement arrachée
contre le projet d'aménagement du bas
belleville initialement proposé par
l'équipe municipale de didier bariani
l'association carte il craint un retour
en force malgré un rapport défavorable
du commissaire enquêteur qui laissait à
la mairie jusqu'au 2 décembre pour
revoir sa copie le projet de zac
ramponneau belleville est inscrit à
l'ordre du jour du conseil de paris du
24 juillet prochain
quand on apprend que l'hôtel de ville
veut faire passer à la session de
juillet le projet de réaménagement qui a
été conçu par la précédente municipalité
on trouve ça complètement anormal on
demande donc que le projet soit remis à
plat et qu'on revoit toutes les
questions qui sont souvent et qui sont
nombreuses notamment suivent on cerne
leur logement sur place et en ce qui
concerne le parti organistique donc
serait pas une beaucoup de choses dans
une lettre l'association label dealeuse
demande au maire socialiste michel
charzat d'intervenir auprès de jean
tiberi à peine installés dans des
bureaux soigneusement vider la nouvelle
équipe du 20e arrondissement entend
appliquer son programme de réexamen de
la zac ramponneau delville pour tout
projet du conseil de paris ne peut pas
être avalisé sans avoir été
préalablement adoptée par le conseil
d'arrondissement
si un projet de cette nature devait
avoir devait passer en force du fait de
l'initiative de la ville de paris il
serait immédiatement ici bloqué chargé
des quartiers sensibles pour la ville de
paris depuis le 25 juin l'ancien maire
udf didier bariani se défend de toute
intrigue
il n'est pas question de passer en force
l'argument que je peux pas accepter
c'est qu'il faudrait en quelque sorte
laissé le temps à la nouvelle mairie
d'arrondissement et aux services de la
ville de prendre connaissance du dossier
car tout le monde ne connaît par coeur
et c'est vrai qu'il ya sûrement un
malentendu entre la ville de paris entre
moi même peut-être et les habitants
belleville parce que ce que nous avons
voulu nous avons voulu que cela et rien
d'autre c'est permettre aux gens de
rester sur place en vivent mieux
résultat du bras de fer entre l'hôtel de
ville et le 20e lundi au conseil
d'arrondissement